on va rejoindre les deux gérard gérard
jugnot et gérard louvin qui sont en
karting
regardez alors attention on voit bien
donc gérard jugnot est en rouge jura
louvard est en grès gérard louvin sans
déconner on dérégule où l'on voit même
pas le kart nouveau sur un cardigan ou
alors le gars tellement content que
j'adore on y va et sans lunettes
autant vous dire que c'est peut-être la
dernière séquence tele2 un bon scénario
c'était le groupe hayot gérard louvin
c'était marjolaine et les millionnaires
c'était greg le millionnaire c'était
l'île de la tentation et bien
aujourd'hui gérard louvin c'est le crash
on y va les trois tours donc gérard
jugnot contre gérard louvin gérard tout
va bien tout va bien merci
j'en ai un qui va le club pour l'instant
attention 3 2 s'ajoutant
les judokas manqué d'en vau l'eau c'est
celle ourak a pris la tête louve a bien
pris la tête d'or l'instant il faut il
doit faire trois tours
attention ouvrez les blacks année
d'accord
ouais
regardez comment gérard chevaucher le
kart gérer vos impressions après la
course c'est tout mon petit c'est tout
je veux gagner parce que je suis touche
pas à mon poste je suis un gagneur comme
monsieur
différentes étaient trop vite